foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show we're dead as dumb
Cassius king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Ken
Coleman Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so Ken it is the time of year when
people reset their lives you've got a
white board that's erased you can write
anything on this new year that you want
there's something grace filled about a
new year and sometimes people kind of do
ish or wish they call it a resolution
and then they change nothing that's
right because the resolution is just
that it's something that I kind of feel
like I want to do maybe there's some
guilt driving the resolution maybe
there's a wish there might have been
some champagne involved that's setting
the resolution that's a good point maybe
even peer pressure goal setting that's a
resolution so we set a resolution but as
you know the data is just abysmal they
all fall off around February yeah Jim
Gibbs gets empty again is is Hell years
ago there were no machines available in
January I was working with a personal
trainer and he said no problem just wait
till Valentine's Day there won't be a
soul in here 45 days in the gym is empty
yeah so that's the difference in a
resolution an ish a wish a goal a goal
is something you actually do goals are
dreams with work boots on and it means
asking what do I need to do differently
what has to be true
that was not true before
to get this Abundant Life
and that's why you're listening to us
you want a more Abundant Life we want
that for you we love you we bust you we
encourage you uh we pray for you uh we
cry with you we do everything on this
show also you can have an Abundant Life
a more Abundant Life and taking the
steps to do intentionality with that so
let's do an old-fashioned goals
setting lesson Ken the old guys I mean
Brian Tracy Ziegler used to say there's
a wheel of life and you need to set
goals and be achieving and growing in
all of these areas you need financial
goals you need intellectual goals you
need family goals spiritual goals
physical goals career goals and social
goals and all of those are important and
generally speaking each of us have one
of those categories or two that we're
really naturally good at comes easy for
us yes and uh one or two that are really
difficult for us that's right and so you
said something earlier I want to just
hone back on you said goals are dreams
with work boots on that implies some
intentionality and diligence to actually
say okay this is what specifically I
want to accomplish and then I've got to
actually get up and do that uh and so I
want to know your thoughts because I
know you've been teaching this for a
very long time certainly with Entre
leadership our business division here at
Ramsey solution so how do we put work
boots on goals when you set a goal then
you have to start start figuring out and
writing down how you're going to
accomplish it okay I want to lose 30
pounds great win okay over 90 days
that's 10 pounds a month 200 pounds a
week now what are you going to do to do
that just just set in the gold and do
anything that's right well I'm gonna
drink more water I'm going to exercise
I'm going to cut out Breads and sweets
okay now we've got some tactical things
we're doing to actually cause the weight
to lose I want to I want to uh get out
of debt okay I gotta get extra job I got
to cut out the subscriptions I got to
sell the stupid motorcycle sit in the
garage whatever it is right and so
you're going to take some actions to hit
the goals and unless you do the needle's
not going to move now goals that work
are just dreams
unless there are five things they need
to a be number one be specific number
two they need to be measurable number
three they need to have a time limit so
I want to lose weight is measurable but
it's not specific
yeah I want to lose 30 pounds is
measurable and specific but then you ask
the question how long do you want you
want up 30 pounds over the next 10 years
or how many times do you want to lose 30
pounds yeah that's okay so I want to
lose 30 pounds over three months now
we've got it like I said a while ago 90
days that's 10 pounds a month two and a
half pounds a week as soon as you put a
time limit on the goal you can back the
math out okay I want to read through the
Bible great when in a year okay 12
months well now we can look at the
number of chapters in The Bible the
number of books in the Bible they have
an Old Testament New Testament read
through the bible plan there's lots of
them I want to run a marathon great win
and now we come back into a training
plan of how many miles I got to run to
get ready for that uh the LA the next
two things is goals need to be in
writing why is it important that they're
in writing
I'm not positive but I have achieved
almost none of my goals in my life if I
didn't write it down yeah the Bible says
in habakkuk habakkuk 2-2 write the
vision and make it plain
I it's almost weird magical but it's uh
you're pretty much ensure it's not going
to happen but something about when it
leaves your mind and you and you write
it and I I would physically write it
like you like to write with a pencil I
do I do absolutely do and I think
there's something that happens there the
in the the physiology of that that
causes us to go okay I'm going to lose
30 pounds and you ride it out I'm gonna
I'm gonna make a hundred thousand
dollars this year and you write it out
that's 8 333 a month that's 2100 a week
what have I got to do to get there you
know and you once you start
putting it on paper it's there and the
last one of the goals it has to be your
goals not your mama's not your wife
that's important my wife wants me to
lose 30 pounds not gonna work my mama
wanted me to be a dentist I don't want
to be your patient okay uh you know
don't live other people's goals live
your goals and you people in leadership
help people set goals that they set when
you set goals for them it's not a goal
it's a quota it's so true and what will
happen is a goal towards a desired
future that's not your desired future is
you just laid out some examples those
goals now become distractions they're
actually distractions from what you
should be doing you'll never finish them
our team's built a guide for you to help
you do goal setting go to
ramseysolutions.com
goals and it'll help you with this
because again you need to touch these
different areas you need to do the seven
different things Financial intellectual
family spiritual physical career and
social and in each of those areas then
you need goals that are specific they
need to be measurable they need to have
a time limit they need to be in writing
and you have to have personal emotional
ownership of them they have to be your
goals and you can put we can put forth a
thousand examples of people that have
done this and how it works and oh by the
way
if you didn't lose 30 pounds but you
lost 28. yeah I think you won yeah
absolutely you know there's an old
phrase out there we don't know who it's
attributed to but the person who aims
for nothing hits it every time and I'll
tell you I've used this this tool this
tool is unbelievable because it guides
you through it so you don't have to
stress out we're going to give you the
categories the financial intellectual
family spiritual physical career social
and we walk you through how to actually
use this and it's going to keep you
accountable oh this is a wonderful guide
to really make some serious gains in all
of these areas in your life in 2023.
well I'll help you with the financial
side because it's free there's that too
yeah that's true all right
ramseysolutions.com goals ish is a wish
drunken resolutions don't count we're
setting real goals this is grown-ups
we're setting goals knock it down baby
get after it this is your year baby go
get it get you some
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
guys we appreciate you listening to the
show obviously this is a service
to you folks Across America by YouTube
by podcast by talk radio and we are
honored to do just that if you want to
help us out we would appreciate it you
can do three things if you want to help
us out doesn't cost you a dime number
one you can subscribe to the show if
you're a YouTube viewer or a podcast
listener just put it on your
subscription it affects the algorithms
and causes people to find us more often
thank you for that you can leave a five
star review and remember my mother
saying if you have anything nice to say
don't say nothing at all and nothing at
all is okay but five stars are better
thank you and uh hey you can also share
it with your friends tell them where you
listen on talk radio or just hit the
share button and share the YouTube link
or the podcast link and we really really
really appreciate that Todd is with us
in Houston Texas hi Todd welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave how you doing better than we
deserve Merry Christmas how can we help
um my wife and I we uh stumble across
your uh baby steps and we're on baby
step one and yesterday
I discovered that I have a Thrift
Savings Account that I have forgotten
about for over 10 years and I'm not sure
what to do with it if we withdraw it and
throw it towards the baby step one and
two or leave it there
how old how old are you
I'm 37. okay how much is in the account
uh a little over 3 200 okay
well here's what's going to happen
mathematically if you pull it out uh do
you still work for the government
no I was in the Army for nine years okay
and I've been out for uh 10. thank you
for your service okay so the proper
thing to do is to roll it to an IRA
because otherwise you're going to get a
10 penalty plus your tax rate so you're
going to pay 30 or 40 percent of this
money out to the government to get it
out so it's kind of like borrowing money
I could borrow 3 200 at 30 interest Dave
would that then pay off my debt would
that be a good idea answer is no right
so uh in a sense that's what you're
doing it's not a lot of money
because it's not a lot of money so it's
really not that big a deal but
conceptually I hate giving the
government 30 percent of the money to
get my money out so instead I would just
roll it to an IRA with a good uh
smartvestor Pro just click smartvestor
pro at uh at ramseysolutions.com and
they'll help you get that rollover done
again it's probably a thousand bucks
it's going to cost you and you'll get
two thousand so it's not like it's
200 000 that we're turning or 300 000
we're turning into 200 000 that would be
an algae moment for sure but it is you
know it is it is improper technique and
so I'm going to be a legalist
and even though it's a small amount just
stick with it Scott's in Allentown
Pennsylvania hey Scott what's up
how you doing sir better than we deserve
how can John and I help
lovely mental and heart tug of war on
putting myself and my wife and our
future first to wipe out my mistakes of
debt versus helping my parents who
should be in near retirement but have
basically not set a great example and
they don't have to act together at all
foreign
so it's been a struggle for me because I
my wife had no debt coming into our
marriage three years ago I do and it's
my responsibility listening to you to
get it all taken care of and then my my
dad's business failed and they didn't
ask for help but then I said hey let me
at least pay your rent this month while
you go find work you need to you know
people roof over your head dad because
that's what you taught me my whole life
and now that I'm rolling into 2023 it's
like hey you know I I did a good thing I
need to go back to focusing on me happy
wife happy life
um
yeah so that's where I'm mentally and
emotionally at right now
are they still coming to you for money
or you still feel like you need to feed
them
no they didn't even want that they said
no we'll figure it out we don't want to
be a burden I'm like uh you already are
so
uh that was my choice volunteering and I
talked it over my wife she said fine if
that's what you want to do for your
Christmas gift for uh yeah you know
because we're married she's like fine
you can give them a month's rent take
care of it I made them give me their
landlord so I paid them directly and
that was just me because I just I was
losing my mind and I just didn't want
them my parents on the street my younger
brother and I have agreed like well we
told them this over the past three years
that the business was going to fail and
they didn't listen so they put
themselves here so there's that tug of
war of like here's here's the deal Scott
there is no tug of war
the greatest gift you can give your
parents long term is for you to take
care of yourself now
okay and if you continue to fight your
wife and her if you've how long have you
been married three years you said
yeah totally Bloomer I'm not 45 so yeah
that's all right that's all right um I'm
just saying uh from a guy who's been
married two decades if that's what you
want to do
is
um spouse speak for stupid wow I
wouldn't do that
all right so if worse than that she said
oh we'll make that your Christmas gift
just uh just a highlight exactly I don't
agree with so you have played your I
wouldn't do that if I were you card
three years in congratulations you spent
it earlier than most of us do but you'd
have
the greatest gift you could give your
parents long term is is to be
financially stable on your own and
you're not is that you're probably being
close like I've been really I just I
shut down all podcasts the past three
weeks and just have been catching up as
much as possible because I used to
listen to a year or two ago and then I
stopped and now I'm like it literally
flipped the flipping switch in my brain
and I told my wife this I said I've not
been a good husband this I shouldn't
even have debt right now I was like I
should have had this paid off a year ago
this is ridiculous because she came from
a family with intelligence of money she
has no debt Hey Hey listen listen that's
in your past who cares you're here right
now what are you gonna do tomorrow
listening to a bunch of podcasts is a
waste of your time if you're not acting
and you listen to watch a podcast and
got all fired up and then you sent your
Christmas money to your parents
yeah well also I also paid off a line of
credit last month and just paid off half
the credit card this month good I'm a
very successful sales person good so get
after that she sees the action get after
it get after it get after it get
yourself out of debt get yourself an
emergency fund get yourself on the road
to Financial Freedom yourself and then
if your parents come to you and say hey
can you support us and you sit down with
your wife and y'all come up with
um here's what our boundaries are and
here's what we're able to do so that we
don't end up in the same situation
that's a whole that's that's a next year
year after that year after that
challenge right now right now you got to
get yourself stable
I love this now how do you get the wife
to my wife to because again she doesn't
have my mistakes so her point is well
and I guess hey we're in this together
like no joke she's got a good amount of
money and she's like well
like that was mine before the marriage
blah blah blah blah and I'm fine with
that no no no no no no then y'all don't
have a marriage you all have a Business
Partnership
that's what it feels like but I want to
I want to bring it up I'm like uh am I
being a jerk saying that like
I'm just trying to approach that in a
teamwork responsibility thing and I'm
like babe I was like if we just have
that one savings account my mistakes are
gone and then I can just pay you back
pay us back
that's no paying back so the old book of
common prayer said unto thee you know
for richer for poor and sickness and
health unto thee all my worldly Goods I
pledge that was the old marriage vows we
quit doing those type of things a
generation or so ago or two generations
ago and that was a mistake because the
proper way to have a high quality
marriage is to share your entire life
right there's no hold back
and so you're not going to sort of help
her if she gets cancer
right you're not you know and well you
used to smoke so you just have to deal
with that cancer thing on your own
and you're not going to do that you're
gonna go well I mean a lady I married
used to smoke and now she's got cancer
and I'm going to take care of her richer
for poorer and sickness and health unto
thee all my worldly Goods I pledge and
so it's not the money
and it's not paying repentance for the
past it's an indication of where the
future is going that we're combining our
incomes we're combining our assets and
we're going to make decisions together
from this point forward
um and we're going to take into
consideration that she was has a natural
skill or a family skill on money that's
above yours and you've got some catching
up to do on that skill but you need to
be sitting down doing that if you can't
do that you guys need to sit down with a
good marriage counselor because you
currently are operating like roommates
relationally
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thanks for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show Dr John deloney Ramsay
personality is my co-host all right
let's go to the psychologist Dr deloni
before we do our next little thing here
I want to revisit the last call because
it is a common
thing out there for second marriages and
late marriages
have more trouble combining their
finances than two 22 year olds that get
married because number one two 20 year
olds get married usually don't have
anything to combine but uh but the other
thing is they're just not there there's
no old dog trying to teach New Tricks
here if you were burned in a marriage
before it makes it hard to trust again
and
um and if you um
you know if you've lived independent and
been responsible and saved up some money
and then you marry someone who has not
been independent and has not been
responsible and has not saved up any
money in his debt
I can see how you would resent that idea
but the thing I don't get I can't get my
head around is how that doesn't go with
the marriage package like you didn't
know you were signing up for this it's
all you see it in late later marriages
it's it's a
it's almost a a compromise like I I just
want to spend time with you I like you
you're hilarious you bring joy to my
life I want to spend time with you I'm
not gonna do business with you right and
I've got friends like some of my close
friends in the world I love them I'd go
to war with them I ain't hiring them
right it's it's kind of like that
when he talked the whole time I kept
thinking oh she doesn't trust you
and whether she might love you she but
she does not trust how you do business
or handle money not not in a in an
Integrity Way but she doesn't trust his
um Financial emotional maturity that's
right and giving money to the parents
who are also irresponsible correct
um added to her suspicions out of guilt
and all that well I mean she's like this
guy's not trustworthy he's he does
stupid butt stuff
you know and that's what's running
through her head but there there's a
thing here that has to happen
um
uh in order to have the highest
probability of becoming very wealthy
you've got to work together and combine
right all the data tells us that in
order to have a high quality marriage
you cannot operate two separate balance
sheets it just does not lend us where
your treasure is your heart is also and
when you combine your finances you're
essentially combining your life you're
combining your future you're combining
your dreams you're combining your fears
and not doing that is sort of like uh
you know I'm gonna just walk around an
ankle deep in the pool of marriage I'm
not going to get in the deep water it's
just like going up to bat and you're
only putting one hand on the baseball
bat when you try to swing it well it's
just not it's not going to be a fact
that's a good one right it's not gonna
be effective and I think in this kind of
in this situation it's a both end
he needs to admit yes the way I've done
it isn't work
so we're going to follow a unified plan
and I will commit to it he said I'm a
great salesman he's one of those he
sells himself a great salesman I'm a
great salesman and one of the things I
suffered with most of us that are great
salesmen suffer with this we think we
can out earn our stupidity uh
and we'll just go make some more money
because making money is easy yeah right
but but it's another scheme another idea
and another but you know it's it's the
way to fix this is I'll just make more
money and it's and because I can always
go do that and um you know I still have
to watch myself on that after even
teaching this for 30 years yeah I said I
can just fix this I'll just go make some
more money because I've always been able
to make money but you know and so up
until I was 28 years old I couldn't keep
it at all and I can get it it's like uh
you had a hole in your live well man you
could catch a lot of fish they just they
just went right out the back of the boat
yeah and we're shocked that when we open
the thing up there's nothing in there we
caught a bunch of fish where did they go
they go yeah it's like the whole thing's
just emptying out so yeah I think uh but
it's the the note is to those of you
that have married late especially or
second marriages especially or are
considering that you need to make this
part of the deal
not because Ramsey said so but because
it's best for your relationship and it
increases your probability of wealth
building you're going to have a higher
quality situation all the way around
when the dude in this case becomes
trustworthy worthy of trust because his
actions are honorable and responsible
and mature and she quits treating him
like a pendulum little kid who is messed
up and I'm going to withhold
uh
my checkbook right from this marriage
right and that's going to require both
people usually to learn a new skill
which is how to have a hard conversation
yeah how to tell each other I don't know
how to do this I'm not comfortable with
you taking care of the money like
instead of going if that's what you want
to do and that's your Christmas present
yeah that was very motherly yeah not
very well very like Aunt susaney yeah
right that was not wifey that was
motherly yeah that was like you're an
idiot little boy just go ahead you're
gonna make a mess spend all your mowing
money on Mountain Dew yeah that's right
you want to do it yeah that's that's
what that was I've heard that tone a
time or two myself so I literally hear
that on a weekly basis
and it's Justified it's Justified
everything all right so these uh
conversation cards have kind of caught
on yes I got a memo today that now a
million dollars worth of them have left
this building it's pretty wild it's
actually closer to a million two now of
these things that you people have bought
out there y'all are desperate for a
conversation somewhere in America this
is pretty amazing these things are
popular John congratulations you have a
hit and let me tell you the the the the
money's cool it's a cool indicator it's
just a way to keep score but the people
send me photos of their thanksgivings of
their conversation the
multi-generational conversations
um the people out just having I always
talk about chips and queso not just on
my show people talk about they have
chips and queso margaritas and they got
the cards splayed out on the table it's
just cool seeing people get together and
be humans together yeah questions for
humans cards looks like a deck of cards
and there's one question on there for
each human and that's how it works so
we've got some we're gonna play right
we're going to play this is a friend's
day deck this is the brand new friends
deck we've got a second edition here so
Dave what this is incredible what are
you ashamed to admit that you let your
pets do
hmm
I um
I go on vacation with us I mean I don't
yeah we take them to the we take them
when they go with the dog it's a little
[ __ ] so he goes with us but I guess
that's kind of frou-frou I don't know
but I mean they don't like he doesn't
misbehave and we just think it's cute
we're older than that my first what is
your my hound dog hound dog that I loved
with all my heart uh I told my my wife
used to she she used to say that dog was
in your bed long before I was but I used
to let that dog that dog's up on my pit
like oh yeah with her head on the pillow
no that doesn't happen no we're not
doing that not even the shitzu yeah not
even anymore I don't want I don't want
the dogs in my in my ZIP code anymore
I'm too old for that crap yeah
um grandbabies don't even sleep in the
bed
yes much less a dog what is something in
our culture that's slowly being
forgotten
Grit
the ability to stick with something
that's hard
and not just abandon it at the first
sign of adversity resilience I was going
to say
um forgiveness and I was been wondering
like what is what it is why can't people
say the words I'm sorry or that was my
fault and I think we've created a
culture where it's one strike and you're
out and you could have had a strike 10
years ago 20 years ago and if if you had
are at fault for a thing
you're done forever if there were cell
phones when I was in college oh gosh I
would be gone
Dave because there would be there would
be pictures and that was the rule like
No cameras what it's wrong with me yes
it would know I mean it would oh no
that's not good at all
we had actual film
yeah Walgreens back in the deer eckards
remember that store back in the day yeah
whoa look at that who would have thought
what item have you held on to that's not
worth much money but it's Priceless to
you
uh
uh tools how old family tools that
actually don't even you don't even use
them anymore yeah but it's tools that
like my Grandpa would have used and that
kind of stuff in there actually they're
not even the they're they're on the
Shelf in my office because they look
cool and they're old and they mean
something to me I don't even keep them
in the toolbox in the garage anymore
that's incredible yeah that's fun hey
check out my questions for humans we
could have gone for a long time yeah
ramseysolutions.com yeah you can get
them they're only 10 bucks so no
purchase necessarily jump in there oh
and uh sign up for the free giveaway
that's what there's no purchase
necessary for there is a purchase
necessary to get these cards but yeah
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author and uh the Creator uh With a
Little Help from his friends all of the
questions for humans cards uh on sale
now at ramsaysolutions.com and a great
addition for the holidays we were just
sampling them for you here a few moments
ago if you missed out so it's a lot of
fun it's a good way to strike up
something that doesn't have to do with
politics or covet uh be nice to have a
conversation that didn't include either
one of those at the fam with the family
ever again during the holidays or with
any human ever the rest of my life that
would be great
except I do want to remind you that back
in no yes I see there you go all right
Anna is with us in Washington DC hi Anna
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you so much for taking my phone
call
um and I am definitely gonna buy several
of those question for human cards now
now that I hear a scene photos well
thank you for that well thank you um I
have my question is my husband and I we
have two houses one is our primary house
and the second one is our old house that
we rented out for two years now and and
my question for you is should we keep
our rental house as a investment or
should we sell it and basically pay off
our primary residence we have 50 equity
on both houses
both mortgages have three percent
interest rates we have no other debt we
have a six-month emergency fully funded
kids college and 401K is funded to the
max so what should we do
we keep it as Investments or should we
sell it and just pay off basically 90 of
all debt yeah you're neither one of
these answers falls in the dumb column
okay
so it's just a matter of uh good or
better and best or something like that
um so one thing that does enter into
this I think you're probably still in
the window to sell the former residents
and qualify for a half a million dollars
of gain tax-free
if you wait another year you won't be
able to because I think I think you got
two years to do that
um can't be rented more than three of
the last five years or something like
that or whatever the number is so check
your Tax Advisor to be sure but that
would enter into the equation for me
because I can free up a half a million
dollars if I do it now tax-free
all right so that that's handy if you
wait a little while the change you know
then then we've just got an investment
property versus your residence same uh
what I personally would do because I
have
enjoyed
the peace
that comes when I don't have a single
payment in the world
and I've enjoyed the ability to build
wealth rapidly when I don't have any
payments
because of that I think it's a shortcut
I've lived it I know it's a shortcut to
sell it and pay off your house
but if you work to pay both of them off
in the next five years you're not dumb
it's just a matter of better or best
so I think best is that when you take a
gulp of air it's going to go all the way
to the bottom of your lungs when you
don't have a house payment
okay
that make any sense
yeah it does that's why I'm asking you
because my husband and I were trying to
figure that out because you know if we
sell it now then we don't have to deal
with the taxes but if we keep it then we
have to keep it for the long haul yeah
yeah you're gonna be landlords forever
and I mean you've already had tenants in
your old house that's an emotional event
oh well they just move and that's why
I'm calling you because now we have an
opportunity no I'm just saying when
other people moving in where you used to
sleep and live and raise your kids and
your dog is just weird
I've got one I got one of my old houses
we used to live in that we rent and it's
still and there's another house uh two
blocks over that's almost identical that
we rent that we own and I don't feel any
emotion about it and I still if the guy
doesn't Park his car right on the one I
used to live in it pisses me off still I
mean it's just weird you know it's kind
of it's kind of awkward does that make
any sense
it does
um but I love going back to my own
neighborhood and seeing my old neighbors
yeah we can do that without a house
yeah that's true
everyone who calls into the show that is
not everyone most people calling the
show who are landlord folks
um
are and Dave tell me if I'm wrong here
but they're when they're into the real
estate game and they want to be
landlords they're all in I rarely hear
somebody that's like I don't know
um it's too hard to screw with if you're
halfway it sounds like she doesn't want
to be a landlord she just doesn't want
to sell that old house no she doesn't
want to do something dumb though and you
know her friends are going oh you always
want investment real estate everybody
knows you want to investment real estate
because everybody is foolish but
everybody knows nothing that's what
everybody knows but yeah so be I mean
that's what you hear is Street knowledge
just people you know your beautician has
an opinion while she's cutting your hair
you know it's everywhere you know and so
it doesn't happen to me but
but uh but I mean you know the guy
changing your oils got investment advice
these days so they saw something on Tick
Tock so they're dead gum expert you know
and that's they're everywhere that's the
that's the thing you have and about real
estate you know you always are taught to
buy real estate you're never taught to
sell it buy always buy investment real
estate always buy a house I always buy
and nobody talks about selling real
estate and there's certain there's some
times it's really good time to sell some
real estate yeah really really good time
Jake is with us Jake's in Orlando
Florida hi Jake what's up
hey good afternoon thanks for taking my
call sure I had a I had a game I had a
game plan I wanted to run by I knew I
could count on you to tell me if there's
a stupid butt idea or not
um
so I love you and I'll tell you the
truth
yes sir absolutely uh got 50 000 in
Consumer Debt
um I've been putting back this last year
for retirement
um I've got about 50 000 in retirement
accounts uh I've got 220 in student
loans
and I have a house
um that I could sell for five roughly
five and I owe 280 on that's your
personal residence
yes sir you're a doctor or a lawyer so
uh I'm anesthesia good pharmacist yeah
okay thank God so you're making what
quarter million yeah
uh I'm basis 190 with overtimes 260 270.
almost like I've done this before okay
yeah right all right and what does she
mean I was
she stays at home with the kids okay
I've got a five-year-old and a
three-year-old
okay um what's your plan
so I'm thinking about taking the what's
in their retirement accounts wiping out
the Consumer Debt uh and selling the
house and wiping out with student loans
uh renting for a year saving the 20 for
the next house and doing things right
moving forward I don't I don't know if
it's a quick hit reset button or suck it
up and buckle down a focus yeah I got
you
well I appreciate your motivation you're
willing to do whatever it takes that's
pretty cool not many people are yes
um but you don't hate your house and
neither does your wife
we love the house okay okay so I almost
never sell the house if I can avoid it
as advice okay it's uh if you can't
afford it we're going to get rid of it
if it's the only way to avoid bankruptcy
we're gonna get rid of it but in your
case you have this huge hole that you're
in and you have this fabulously large
shovel
right so no I'm gonna in order to keep
the house though the family is going to
commit to a couple of three years of
beans and rice and no vacations
no lifestyle we're not living like a
rich doctor because we're not we're a
broke doctor
right so no and you never cash out your
retirement to pay off debt unless it's
to avoid bankruptcy or unless you have
you know two million dollars and you're
68 years old you know I mean penalties
we might do it then but not now we're
not doing this with penalties so stop
adding to retirement get on a beans and
rice budget the two of you commit to
completely cleaning up all of your 270
000 worth of debt with your 250 000
income so let's say we did 90 a year
that's three years
yes sir and that's what I would do if I
woke up in your shoes uh because it sets
you free for the rest of your life then
uh to to invest and with this fabulous
income and your income's not going to do
anything but go up you're not been out
that long
and how old are your kids again
uh five and three perfect so let me tell
you on the back end of this what this
looks like um your two little kids are
gonna get to watch you
um struggle and make do and y'all make
dinner at home even when you're tired
and they're going to take some
incredible lessons from this they're
going to change them forever and so I
would tell you don't Rob them of a
three-year learning opportunity watching
their dad and mom do really hard things
they get to watch this thing it's gonna
be great
and you can always sell the house if you
have to but you don't have to this is
the Ramsay show
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 mil
show every week a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country to find a
station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay shop where debt is done cash is
King in the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the Dr John deloney
show is my co-host today as we answer
your questions about your life and your
money open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Ramel is with
us in Long Island New York hi Rommel how
are you
hey Dave and John how are you better
than we deserve sir how can we help nice
um all right I'm a long time listener
first-time caller
um I mean I'm just so far into debt and
I'm I'm scared and I don't know which
way to go with it and it's like uh you
know every time I get paid it's like I'm
on a vocal so I just go round and round
and nothing's nothing's getting done
and I'm just way over my head with
everything
how much do you owe man
um between credit cards and my stupid
carpet my stupid car loan um I'm at 45
000. okay what do you make
um I make uh
about 33 an hour
so I bring uh before taxes about 1300
but I bring home after taxes around nine
nine seventy a week are you married um I
did yes I am married four kids my wife's
a stay-at-home mom okay cool and um what
do you owe on the car in particular
at all 11 11 8 on it okay
so the credit cards are uh you didn't
like take a big trip or celebrate
something this is just life has happened
with this chaos and it ended up on the
credit card because you couldn't pay it
all exactly yeah that's normal multiple
credit cards that's normal that fits
that fits with what you were describing
a while ago the sense of being a rat and
a wheel so here's the thing if you and
your wife were to sit down
today in front of John and I and we were
just sitting there at our kitchen table
and all four of us talking
would we see two people that are
sick and tired of being sick and tired
are you ready to
go through the pain of change
because the pain of the current
situation sucks enough
I'm absolutely absolutely on board where
you know it's it's she you know
oh yeah 100 percent
okay
because that's a big deal I mean if you
can't because some people like the pain
of the chaos more than they like the
pain of change because changing is a
pain in the butt yeah because you're
getting ready to do some uncomfortable
stuff to break this cycle and you got to
be ready for that
yes what do you do for a living
I work on a school bus I'm a mechanic
okay
uh how old are your kids
uh my oldest is 16 my son is 10 my
daughter's eight and my youngest is uh
five
okay
so here's the thing
um
no more eating out
no
and I think that's a big big issue oh it
is sure it is your wife is a
stay-at-home mom she now by God Cooks
yep all right that's her job she's a
home economist that's her part in this
uh and and when you get home uh put the
kids to bed and turn off the television
okay and we're going to start a budget
tonight and the two of you are going to
start telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went
okay
because it's a where are you where
you're sitting emotionally is a helpless
hopeless feeling it feels sharp and out
of control
yep and you know I had it when last week
I told my wife you know I'm worth more
dead than alive because I did take one
thing from your lesson we both got uh
turned life insurance good what lesson
is that you went through Financial Peace
University no no just you know from here
from the from the talk shows talk about
current time okay
I got to tell you that that was a a
stupid thing to say because it's not
true
you're not worth more dead than alive
you might be worth more money at this
instant but not more money over the
scope of your life you're earning power
through the scope of your life much
exceeds that and the uh economic and
actual arithmetic value to your children
not to mention
the actual fatherhood to your children
but the actual math of what it does to
your family far exceeds that life
insurance so you're you're very valuable
to your family sir
okay thank you I needed that yeah and
that that's that's not just valuable in
a spiritual sense which is true but I'm
talking about the arithmetic you are
actually worth more life mathematically
okay so and what we know the other
part's true yeah you're worth more as a
dad you're worth more as a person you're
a good guy I've enjoyed talking to you
for a few minutes here so
and you've you've got it
whenever we get wound up in to like it
feels like we're drowning right and
you've got this debt and it's hanging
over you
there's also the chaos of you work for
on school buses
yes yeah you're you have been caught in
that mess of a system in New York for
the last 36 48 months and it's been a
disaster yeah and you have a
five-year-old all the way up to a 16.
your house is a zoo right now
yep right and so everything feels like
it's coming apart at the seams I need
you to hear me say this it's not
when you have a 16 year old and a 10
year old and a five-year-old and what
was the other one eight eight
dude you're just gonna have underwear in
weird places in your house and you're
just gonna have pee in weird like I
don't know how this works geometrically
how where P how it got this way in the
bathroom some of that just is and some
of that is uh not going to war not
declaring Civil War on Rommel okay okay
you're a dad who's in a wild it's a
winter and there's no reason to go
outside and scream because it's snowing
it's winter so put a coat on man you
know what I mean and so you're in a wild
season what can you control right now
you can control this debt and let's get
on this plan you can control your
marriage you can control how much you
and your wife get together on the same
page and that's the beauty of getting on
this plan together yeah we're going to
put you into Financial Peace University
and pay for it okay if I pay for it and
give it back if I pay for it and give it
to you will you promise me you will do
every single thing we say to do in the
lesson
yes sir and your wife
and my wife 100 okay let me let me one
up and you promise if you ever ever have
a thought again
I think my family would be better if I
wasn't here
if you ever have that thought again do
you promise you will reach out to
another man that you trust and say I'm
not doing all right yes I will you
promise yes promise got it okay you're
you're a great guy and you're gonna be
fine and I've in 30 years I've walked
with hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of people just like you you're going to
be 100 debt free you're going to be on a
budget you're going to have an emergency
fund of 15 or 20 000 and you and your
wife are going to have the best
communication that you've ever had in
the history of your marriage so far if
you will follow the stuff we teach you
to do I'll show you exactly how to do
every bit of that it's not costing you a
dime so it works dude it works it
changes everything when you lean into
this so you hold on we'll pick up and
get you signed up this is the Ramsay
show
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host to set today Proverbs says hope
deferred makes the heart sick
this time of year
when things aren't going right it's like
exaggerated
and if they're not going right with your
money and you're trying to buy presents
or you feel the pressure to buy presents
or you feel the pressure to travel and
you know the money it's exaggerated it
doubles and triples and 10x is the
stress
hope
can start to slip away
but um
when desire comes it is the tree of life
now what that means is that when you can
pull back most of the time when you lose
your Hope on things and John you could
probably give me some actual data on
this but my perception of working with
someone that's lost their hope it it's
because they've got whatever's going on
pushed right up in their face and the
smallest thing seems awfully big when
you put it right in front of your eyes
if you can push it out and get it in
perspective of life
it it all is Small Stuff hmm oh just as
you were talking I was thinking oh
there's some classic studies
um
old psychological studies about learned
helplessness that when I when I keep
striking out that little thing like I
just quit and then something comes back
I I I I don't even bother when a new
opportunity shows up I just this is the
way I am this is the way I do it I
screwed up I've tried this plan I tried
that plan or whatever I'm just whatever
yeah I'm not good at math I'm not good
at math so I can't do it yeah I I tried
that Bitcoin thing it blew uh I got a
closet full of Beanie Babies I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I just this is the way it is I'm
not good at this yeah there's money
thing I can't do I just can't do it yeah
but it all that is is you just had the
crap beat out of you right and you just
don't have any you don't have anything
left there's no juice left and so but
but in in that what has happened is is
that you've believed a lie because you
took small things and put them really up
close in your face and they look like
big things yeah I mean I can take my
grandson's little tiny dinosaur and put
it right in my face and it looks like a
real dinosaur
it looks like a T-Rex is coming to eat
me you know and that's the way that you
say it's but when you put it back in its
perspective you go oh it's a little toy
look at that and it changes everything
and that's the way this stuff is and you
know uh like when our kids are upset
about something that we realize is
nothing it's kind of cute you know your
little kid is your little
five-year-old's really upset about a
broken toy and like their life is coming
to an end and they go wait a minute we
could just put the wheel back on it it's
okay oh you know it saved their life
because they were about to die right
there on the but and so it's kind of
cute and I think God sometimes looks at
us when we're when we think that oh God
we're in drama queen mode he's just like
oh we'll just put the wheel back on it
so it's just it's just it's okay you're
fine you're gonna be okay hey our
question today comes from blinds.com 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping and with
a new promo they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code Ramsay
to get the best possible deal all right
today's question comes from Thomas in
Maine Thomas writes I've done all that I
can
oh I love it when a sentence starts when
something starts out that's pretty
definite yep I've explained to the
babies
I need to stop interrupting but I can
already tell you where this is headed
I've done all that I can I've explained
the baby steps without rudeness or anger
I've never tried to control my wife
I helped her pay off nine credit cards
everything was fine and we were on fire
until about a month ago then my wife
started using credit cards we already
paid off and just got another one in the
mail yesterday
I was told my money is none of Dave
Ramsey's business and none of yours
so she's decided it's Christmas time and
she's gonna do what she wants my wife
has a master's degree in Communications
she refuses to take a job that uses her
degree so instead of her making three to
six thousand dollars a month she makes
two thousand dollars a month at a job
with no benefits my wife also has
student loans that are now officially
none of my business I'm very confused
very hurt and angry my instinct is to
give up and in the marriage this isn't
the first money argument we've had and
it won't be our last I don't see where
we are going financially or in our
marriage am I wrong for being angry
about this situation
whoo
honestly if if Thomas was here and he
just said this to me I would stop I
would take out my headphones my my
earpieces and I would give Thomas a hug
like it's just hard
it's just hard
um it sounds like he is at resent the
resentment and that's a hard place to be
in your relationship it's hard place to
come back from
um Dave I can I I don't know a lot but I
can guarantee this this isn't about
money
this is about something else going on in
their relationship oh this is about
control yeah and power and explaining
power struggle yeah and has been ongoing
for a long time right and so he
weaponized me
yeah
weaponized Dave Ramsey in your house
I'll just tell you it doesn't work okay
if you go around and say Dave Ramsey
said nobody gives a crap what Dave
Ramsey says they truly don't
uh what they care about is is
information that'll change their life
that's what they care about and they
don't care that it came from me it adds
no it's it does not it you know if you
turn my name into a cuss word or Ramsay
in general into a cuss word in your
house you did not accomplish a thing and
that so this is about control
if this marriage is gone unless you guys
get some in-depth counseling because you
are both uh have crossed the line of the
The Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse as
Les perrett talks about in his marriage
seminars
um one of them is contempt and contempt
if when you reach a relationship with
anyone where you look at them with an
eye roll
that it means you are contemptuous of
them it means you have completely lost
any respect for them your need to serve
them
and love them is just gone this is all
about I have to tolerate your presence
and you stink you need a bath it starts
to feel that way that's the way the
sound's done it absolutely and it's it's
coming both directions right oh yeah
yeah
she's completely had it with him and
dude you can say I've done all that I
can explain this with baby steps or
without rudeness or anger and then the
last line in the email is Am I Wrong to
be angry
there's a little inconsistency here
you've been pissed about this stuff a
long time
and um and you've you know she has a
degree in Communications and refuses to
use it that's true
but not about our career
she sucks at communication but also
people will they will cash out their
dreams they will cash out their
professional Ambitions to prove a point
right they will drive themselves into
debt because you're not gonna tell me
what to do yeah you said this is about
power and this is about
I'm tired of you talking down to me this
is about I'm tired of you telling me how
I have to do whatever is this is a
marriage that is hanging on by a yeah
been a lot of uh you should you need to
in this house both of your Gunners both
of you instead of uh Hey what if we
looked out there and saw a really bright
place in the future and we walked
towards it together
that's a much more persuasive
methodology then you know if you'd get a
good job instead of working at half of
what you're worth we could clean this
mess up you lazy woman well if you would
just if you'd quit talking down to me
explain it's my money Dave Ramsey can
kiss my butt
and we're just gonna do this in circles
and in circles and in circles uh uh
what's our buddy that did that love and
respect uh he calls it the crazy cycle
oh yeah yeah it builds on itself and it
just spins the tornado that's right it
spins out it's uh what is it uh Elder
yeah
uh gosh I'll have to go look it up love
and respect is a great book it's a great
marriage book so Thomas this is this is
when I talked bad yes and you've got to
stop to fight this is when you walk in
and you lay down your sword you lay down
your shield and say I'm not fighting
anymore because this isn't about a fight
this is about getting on the same page
yeah if we can't get on the same page
this is over this is a civil war and
we're now we're just shooting grenades
at each other and we're going to end up
killing our family and our friends and
our neighbors just shuts down in the in
the Civil War in the United States
family shot family that's right and
that's right friend shot friend that's
what you're doing yeah stop stop don't
fire another weapon
just go sit down on her side of the
couch and say listen you're nothing
wrong to be angry but it's not working
for you yeah
stop explaining you guys are gonna get
some help you're in eye roll you're in
contempt it is one of the four things
that ends relationships permanently
contempt is very hard to come back from
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're glad
you're here it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Paul's in New York City hi Paul welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi Dave and John thanks for taking my
call um I just think I just finished The
Total Money Makeover and um my rent's
over 50 of my take-home pay
um I'm a single dad that just went
through a really long and expensive
divorce and I'm just trying to figure
out how to get my situation under
control wow sorry
that's horrible well I mean can we agree
that 50 of your take-home pay
is not mathematically sustainable
yes absolutely and and the hard part is
uh I so I have a two bedroom apartment
uh so that my son has space and
um my rent is relatively affordable for
Brooklyn yeah unfortunately yeah I don't
doubt that I mean you live in one of the
most expensive real estate markets in
the world
yeah so that I don't doubt that but
obviously you don't make enough money to
live there
yeah
so one of the two things if you want to
have a sustainable life and not end up
with you know substantial Financial
damage to your life
or you struggle and have stress you're
going to either increase your income
in the next months or even year
um dramatically or you're going to move
well the uh the situation becomes uh
even more complicated when so I have
split custody of my son and in our
agreement
um the his his school is already set to
stay in Brooklyn
um
for the next
four years and then we would have to
work out where High School is which
would most likely stay in the city and
I'm already I live in a neighborhood
where his school is and I already
commute an hour into my job in Manhattan
was your divorce
um
was it amicable to just sit down and
shake hands or was it a mess
it was a mess okay
um
what do you do for a living
I'm a photographer
okay
You're Gonna Change careers or you're
gonna move yeah
yeah because dude I mean regardless of
the constraints that you and your
ex-wife and the courts have put on you
none of you get a pass on math because
we decided these things math is still
going to kick your butt
yeah and I I would love to just wave a
wand and make this all okay I don't but
I don't my magic wands are low on
batteries
so something is going to change and
you're either going to change it or it's
going to be changed for you
because this is not sustainable
bad things are going to happen and force
you out of this situation
and um you're just not able to be there
it's that simple or good things are
going to happen and you find different
housing a different housing Arrangement
you find uh and more income to be able
to sustain this but it's just uh it's
not like a Dave Rule and it's not like
oh here's the best thing you can do this
is you know you simply cannot survive
doing this long term I mean you can
survive for a few months or maybe a year
but you've got to have a plan to develop
a life
that that works and this doesn't work
this is going to lead to homelessness
and
that's at the end of this line this just
becomes a mess is because you've created
a an unsustainable you created a very
anxious life
I'm just thinking about this little boy
that comes home and half of his life
comes home to a exhausted stressed out
dad who's trying to figure out how to
give his kid this magical life like you
mentioned it's got this that math
doesn't apply to that can barely afford
rent they can barely afford groceries
and that's a kid constantly coming home
to a tense home to an anxious home
and that means we gotta we got to change
that whole thing because it is this
whole thing's gonna end in Ash but
you're also going to end with a frazzled
exhausted kid who feels responsible for
making sure dad's okay and that's not
your kid's job and so man I I think now
you're going to start looking to take
pictures in the evenings and on weekends
and at Big Wedding events and you're
gonna have to find yourself a job where
you're gonna make way more money yeah
something's going to give
so
um
I I always suggest if we're going to
have pain let's choose the pain instead
of letting it choose us yes every time
and there's 100 of the situation that's
going to have pain
so choose the pain the pain is a career
change an adjustment to what type of
Photography you do or when you do it the
pain is moving the pain is a different
housing situation within the constraints
of the neighborhood which is probably
very difficult but there's something is
going to give you can't just sit here
and go in the name of all that is noble
and good for my child I'm going to
pretend like this isn't happening
because it's going to happen to you
you cannot sustain the situation
um it's just that simple and it's a it's
not me that's just 30 years of coaching
people and counseling people that are in
trouble and dude you're trouble looking
for a place to happen right now and
let's let's we talked about this in an
earlier segment
let's don't forget you have the
opportunity to teach your son over at
one to two to three to four year period
what it looks like to change Midstream
to get that grit and resilience we were
talking about that earlier segment to
develop new skills and new strength and
see his dad go back to school and see
his dad get qualified for new jobs he is
dead do all these really hard gritty
things
for his son for the sake of his family
tree moving forward
it's not going to be pleasant at the
time but man you're giving your kid a
gift yeah you've got to get this
situation healthy because I will give
you
unless your ex-wife is an anomaly
she's also facing the same thing you're
facing
unless she's like you know
a heart surgeon or something and and you
know uh in in Manhattan you know making
500k she's probably also facing the same
thing
so if she could be an anomaly but if
she's trying to do it could be you all
had two average to below average
incomes when combined made it work in
the city
but split up both of you are screwed
that may be where you are and so your
kid may be going from one stressed house
to another stressed house to John's
Point likely is I don't know I don't
know your ex's situation but uh and I'm
not going to get into that that doesn't
matter but I'm just saying there's a
high probability that's going on too so
she's she doesn't get a pass on math
just because she's pissed at you either
math catches up with you it works in New
York it works in California it works in
Abilene Works in Tulsa and it works in
Nashville and it always works the same
because it's math
and you just cannot run from it uh and
it's not a Dave thing it's not a Ramsay
thing it's not a hateful thing it's not
a racist thing it's just math when we
live in a in a culture that says follow
your passion and follow your dreams well
my dream is to be a photographer in
Manhattan like I'm going to go to the
epicenter of all that is fashion and all
that is high society and I'm going to be
a photographer I'm going to capture and
be an artist
and then all of a sudden you get
divorced and rent doesn't care what your
dreams are
rent just cares what the dollar amount
is yeah I'm sorry I'm heartbroken for
you man I'm sorry you're facing this
it's hard and I'm not belittling
uh how painful this is I'm just begging
you to choose your pain because of all
the other pain you've been through and
in the name of creating a fantasy land
for your child sometimes people don't
choose the pain and it will choose you
if you don't choose it
so pick your poison
what's it going to be
something's going to move and I strongly
suggest to you my friend that you do the
moving instead of the moving being done
on you
because not acting is going to bring
this to your doorstep
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Steve is in Burlington Vermont hi Steve
welcome to the Ramsay show hello Dave
and John it's a privilege to speak with
you this afternoon you too what's up
well uh after listening this afternoon I
feel very very lucky uh I commiserate I
feel bad for those folks that are having
a tough time but there is hope and I I
just got to validate you on on the seven
baby steps that's helped me over the
years even though I've made some
mistakes along with you know the road of
life but
today I want to ask about rnds
and whether it's smart to take more than
the required minimum distribution from
my IRA to help pay down the rest of my
mortgage cool good for you well done
Steve so what is your total Nest Egg how
much money do you have in investments in
total
uh I have about 450
000 in an IRA
I have uh forty thousand dollars no 48
43 000 today in my savings account which
I consider my emergency fund
I also have a life insurance life
insurance policies that I could cash in
and I'm thinking of doing that would
give me uh roughly another sixteen to
seventeen thousand dollars
and what do you owe on your mortgage a
hundred and fifty three thousand okay
well it's kind of on the bubble if you
cashed out enough of your Investments to
pay off the mortgage
um you're only going to have what 300
Grand or so left over right
right
and I wouldn't want to do all of that
but here's what I was thinking uh my
income puts me into 12
tax bracket
if I take uh
withdrawals from the IRA and keep it
below the the next step in in the tax
wouldn't that make sense yeah it does it
does yeah and begin to whittle away at
it do you have any income how old are
you
I am 73 years old I am a retired
firefighter I have a pension
that brings me about 43 000 a year my
wife is a retired flight attendant and
she brings in about 32 34 000 a year so
you're in good shape without this money
without the money in the ira yes yeah I
mean you don't need that you don't need
an income off of it to live
no no so yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
probably pull down pretty aggressively
on this thing and let's get this move
towards getting this mortgage paid off
now that I have this pension information
knowing you've got that income coming
out yeah I just I I I'm with you I I
can't if you told me you had 800 000 to
pay off your house in full today
you know
because it would it would still leave a
sizable Nest Egg and I just we're
getting it I'm kind of getting in that
nervous range I mean 300K left over is
nothing to sneeze at you've done a
wonderful job way to go sir
but um
I just don't want to get things down
that low it starts to bother me uh so
yeah let's uh let's move towards getting
the house paid off out of your income
and out of your rmds your required
minimum distribution for those of you
out there listening at 72 and a half
year or start it you're required to
begin to draw down on traditional 401ks
and IRAs because the government wants
their tax money in so they're not going
to let you let it lay there and grow tax
deferred anymore they're going to make
you take a minimum out according to a
formula called the rmd the required
minimum distribution so he's got to do
that plus a little plus a little more
right up next to or maybe even up a
whole another tax bracket still not
going to be much in taxes and
um just go ahead and push that mortgage
out of the way as quickly as you can I
bet you can do it in two or three years
without tearing into this nest egg and
that's that that's where I want you to
head towards so good question man I love
that and Dave let me ask you this
it feels like being 75
let's say fast forward to I'm 75 years
old what I prefer to have
a quote-unquote safe nest egg or zero
liability
because I always feel like I don't have
any payments yeah that feels like my
best move well I do want you to have no
payments for sure
the thing is if we can ease into this
and knock it on out in a fairly
reasonable period of time and preserve
the mistake because once you pull that
out of that 401k you can't put it back
right
so you got to build it over here on the
side and you don't have the tax
protections of being in that 401k so I I
would slow pedal this because at any
moment that you wanted to you cash it
out and pay it off
right in one day but with in with the
with two pensions coming in
if you have no payments and one of you
suddenly has to go to an assisted living
you have to get a nurse and you can cash
flow that making 75 000 a year again you
could just write a check that day yeah
if something happened if something
changes because you can just okay you
can you can you can't undo the decision
to pull it out but you can make the
decision to fill it out at any point so
that's a much more measured approach so
you're saying I'm going to lean into it
over the next three years if something
else intersects the situation like uh a
health thing or something then then you
know we may want to reach over and just
knock it out gotcha well we can always
do that it's always there there you go
but you can't undo it yeah okay and and
that's that's true uniquely
in this age in his age that's not true
of you 45 year olds you need to go
freaking pay your house okay that's a
different thing so don't take
you know permission you know if you're
sitting on a pile of money that's not in
your retirement account you can pay off
your house today and you're 45 shut up
and do it that's a different scenario
because you've got time to build your
nest egg
but uh at 72 uh you know we we want to
treasure that and protect that egg as
much as we can Jeff is in Lancaster
Pennsylvania hi Jeff welcome to the
Ramsay show lencast hi thank you wow
thank you so much for taking my call
it's an honor to be talking to you guys
um I think based on your comments just
there and have an idea of what you're
going to sing but I have a similar uh
situation to the last caller here
um we had a fantastic year as a as a
business my wife and I own a small
business here in Lancaster and um uh we
have we're on data step six
um and we have about in a non-retirement
savings account we have about
575 uh thousand dollars in there our
mortgage on our house is 374.
and we were planning on paying off our
house here relatively soon we just had a
baby a couple weeks ago congratulations
Merry Christmas Yes
um but we didn't do very good tax
planning on how profitable we were so
we're looking at a 200 000 tax bill
um and then the estimates that were that
we have now talked about with our
accountant for the next couple years so
I guess the question is so you don't
have 575 you have 375. right so we have
yeah we have to pay that tax obligation
yep down you know if you don't if you
don't pay it soon it's going to get a
penalty yeah right and if you've done
you've underpaid your quarter lease yeah
yeah so I guess the question is do we
use the rest of that savings account to
pay off our house or should we say that
okay where'd the 575 come from
um you got an incredible year you said
profitable right we did yes an
incredibly profitable year why would he
not make that next year
uh uh we're planning on making that next
year as well it's good yeah
um also just the tax portion of it we
have to plan for better yeah but I mean
you know if you can make an extra 600
000 and the government takes their pound
of Flesh that's part of the equation
you know because I mean you're evil you
must be punished
this is our policies today so yeah my
favorite was uh yeah we we just we kind
of missed on taxes how bad 275 thousand
dollars just a bit outside yeah so
here's the thing is you're you're gonna
you're gonna do what else with the money
what else would you do with it
uh I mean we had planned on expanding
our business uh opening another
store in a different city close by yeah
I would do that next year with next
year's money after you have a paid for
house
okay and do that with cash that's left
over after taxes I like making sure this
business can can it's not just a flash
in the pan it can do two years in a row
before I start expanding I love that
idea yeah yeah well he's obviously got
something that's working beautifully
yeah proud of you I do want you to
expand I want you to expand with cash
only not with debt and while you're
sitting in a paid for house you make
different decisions at your business
good question sir Merry Christmas
congratulations this is the Ramsay show
Dave here you can find
shows with the Ramsay Network app on
your smartphone it's the only place to
listen to the entire back catalog of
episodes download the Ramsay Network app
in your favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John deloney Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and host of the
Dr John deloney
famous podcast is my co-host today open
phones here as we talk about your life
and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Patrick starts us off in Louisville
Kentucky Merry Christmas to you Patrick
what's up
uh Merry Christmas to y'all too how can
we help today
my question is
I'm a divorced single father of three
and I'm having a hard time staying
on a budget I don't have anybody to hold
me accountable
so that's kind of my question it's like
what do I do to find something like that
that can hold me accountable
who's your best friend
uh
probably an older older couple that
lives down the road from me
sounds like a candidate
yeah let me ask you another question why
have you chosen not to have somebody in
your life that can hold you accountable
that's a choice you've made for a reason
how come
well I would say it's probably uh
where I went through my divorce and
everything I kind of just
shrunk back here for a while
there you go and you know I just don't
get too close I guess hey that's fair
I'll give that to you man
and you've you've you've unfortunately
had to learn the hard way that you can't
do Life by yourself right
right it's hard it's real hard
and so we talked about an earlier
segment Dave and I you're at a point
where you've got to choose your heart
you can choose to White Knuckle your way
through life raising three kids without
any buddies to walk alongside you
without any people who are 10 or 15 or
20 years down the road from you who can
give you some wisdom
without another romantic without another
wife right you can do that or
um you can choose the other hard path
which is I'm gonna slowly uh open myself
back up to relationships again that's
your two choices and and you are seeing
in real time that one of those is not
working
yeah so I think you know what happens is
in a divorce usually is uh you you lose
some friends to the uh one side or the
other right and uh yeah yeah I kind of
they chose a side so to speak and that's
not unusual uh so some people you
thought were going to be standing beside
you including her are not there anymore
and so yeah you've got to go reset your
friend group and uh the need for
accountability on this one thing on the
budget is just pointing that out
right and my guess is you probably
haven't gotta building I don't really
talk with very many people yeah so it's
time yeah
it it my guess is this isn't the only
thing you need accountability on right
right
yeah I mean you're walking through one
of the hardest things you've ever walked
through in your life doing that alone is
super tough yeah so yeah the couple down
the street the people at church the uh
if you're not in a good church it's time
to hunt one up maybe grab a couple
buddies from from where you work and
invite them over to your house to watch
the fights and just y'all do whatever
get an online group with one of the
online FPU classes yeah jump into one of
the Financial Peace University classes
and get you know get accountability it's
probably a church in your area teaching
it uh we had a 11
000 FPU classes taught this year wow so
not at this particular moment but
throughout this year there have been so
you can hopefully you can find one there
in Louisville to plug into but uh
that'll give you the accountability
that's all around this particular
subject and who knows you might strike
up with some friendships in there it's
not unusual for those people on those
financial University groups to become
lifelong friends because they fighting
that they're fighting the same battle
against the same dragons or or find a
find a a singles dad's group or a
divorced dads group um they're in your
local area man reach out and do that
yeah there's some great churches in your
Market that we're familiar with so yeah
I'd plug in but you know here's the
thing it's just it's normal to go
through that and you've got to move on
to the next thing Dave is in Pittsburgh
hi Dave welcome to the Ramsey Show
uh hi David Dr John I appreciate you
taking my call it's an honor to talk to
you guys today you too Merry Christmas
how can we help
thank you Merry Christmas
um I have an uncle who is wanting to
gift
um a piece of property to one of his
sons myself and my sister and I'm just
having a hard time trying to figure out
whether or not it's a good idea
um my wife and I are on baby step four
five and six right now how many acres
[Music]
um
it's maybe two two and a half
um
what's it worth
I'm sorry what's it worth
uh I I don't have a dollar amount no I
mean it's a two million dollars or a
hundred thousand or fifteen no
it's it's probably a hundred and hundred
and fifty thousand
okay uh I I would if he called me and
asked me to if he should do this I would
tell him no
because you've got three different
people with three different sets of
motivations that are now co-owners in
something this is an opportunity for you
guys to get in a really big family fight
right and I I if I were in his shoes I
would just leave I would just give you
some money
and sell the property to give you the
money
it's a lot easier
yeah I was um it just it was
it just came up the other day and he
kind of dropped it on my lap and I'm
just kind of emotional about it so I
wasn't yeah I didn't want to make a bad
decision because of emotion you know I
mean my advice to him would be to don't
do it this way because it's going to
cause he's trying to be a blessing and
he's going to cause unintended problems
that he doesn't see coming
sure and that's if your sister and your
cousin and you all really love each
other it's still tough because they're
married to somebody who has a dream
about a trailer park they want to open
and somebody else wants to start a
hunting lease on these two acres I mean
it just gets out it gets off the rails
quick man
yeah hey how is your how old is your
uncle
uh he's probably he's about 78.
in good health
fairly uh they're trying to put a plan
in place because they can see themselves
not being able to be there long term at
this point yeah
so Dave let me let me ask you a question
on behalf of of Dave here
um I'm talking to Dave Ramsey let me ask
you a question on behalf of Dave
let's say his uncle he talks his uncle
and says I don't think this is a wise
saying it probably best if you sold it
and we can just split the money that way
and he says all right I'll take that
under consideration and then he hands
everybody an envelope at Christmas and
it says I've given you three this do you
reject the gift
or do you accept the gift just knowing
that at some point I'm not going to
fight my brother and cousin over the
like yeah I would just hold it if if the
gift is put up in your hands anyway I
would just hold it very openly and kind
of let the other two win all the fights
I just I because if you enter into this
like this is
life-changing stuff and everybody's
going to argue over every little nuanced
thing it's just not worth it and if it
gets really heated I just do a quick
claim deed and give them give the other
two my ownership I would not this is a
recipe for everybody to be pissed off I
very few of these things work out well
very few of them this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for being here hey if you're a small
business owner and you've got questions
about business we're going to be doing
an entree leadership theme hour here on
the show and we want your questions we
want to get in touch with you have you
participate in the show be a caller
you've got questions about hiring and
firing questions about family business
questions about marketing questions
about running your business I have run
this business for 30 years
so I'm uniquely qualified to answer your
business questions it's what I do we
teach leadership All Over America all
over the world for that matter so you
get the opportunity to call in for free
no cost for this kind of coaching pretty
cool it's an entree leadership theme
hour uh you need to email in and get in
line
you email you the email address you use
is ask
at ramsesolutions.com put entree
leadership theme now on the subject line
ask at
ramseysolutions.com well it is the
Christmas season but with the Island of
Misfit Toys in Washington DC we've got
words like recession and inflation and
gas prices in the news crazy out there
but join me and Rachel Cruz George
Campbell Dr John deloney Ken Coleman
this spring in a city near you for our
Building Wealth live event tour we're
going to teach you the proven plan to
inflation proof your money
build lasting wealth
apply these principles to your life in a
real and a practical way the first event
will be in Nashville here in our home
headquarters we'll be doing that on
January the 12th and then we'll be in
Indianapolis on February the 16th Austin
Texas February 23rd Salt Lake City Utah
April 24th in Anaheim California May the
second event passes start out at just 49
don't wait all of our fall Building
Wealth events and last spring all sold
out early these will too get your
tickets now they make great stocking
stuffers ramseysolutions.com
events John is with us in New York hey
John welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you Dave yeah thank you for
talking to me sure what's up
um my wife and I are
at the point where we're we have we
actually took Financial Peace back in
the early 90s back in Dallas
um and we set up a plan and we've been
working towards that plan since then to
retire around the age of 55. we're close
to there now
um we've got about 2.5 million net worth
good for you now that we're that close
we're scared kind of scared to pull the
trigger
okay what are you scared of um uh just
that we don't have enough saves
um how much do you need to live on
uh you know the
difference well no kidding what do you
need to live
generally to live on I think we can live
50 to 75 a year Max okay well if I mean
if you've got two and a half million if
it's generating a 10 rate of return
that's 250 000 a year without touching
the two and a half million
see that's a I like that number better
than you know I looking at you know the
traditional four percent withdrawal and
concerns about whether that was well I
mean it has everything to do with what
you've got to invested in if you're if
you're drawing four percent you've got
it all sitting in one percent accounts
you're going to tear into the principal
right
right but if you're drawing six or eight
percent and the thing is growing at ten
or eleven percent on average
then you're going to be growing your
account every year and still pulling off
a couple hundred grand
okay you're making me feel much more
confident well I mean are you invested
in good mutual funds that have a long
track record of north of 10 percent
uh yes well there's our
return averages right around 10 percent
okay over the last 10 plus years okay
and so if it averaged that over the next
10 plus years and you pulled off eight
percent it would grow by two percent a
year
if you pulled off six percent it would
grow by four percent a year
right yes I mean now some years it's
going to be down some years it's going
to be up if like you said it average is
10 which means some years you made 15
and some years you made four
but on average if you're pulling off
eight and on average it's making eleven
you've got a growth rate of three which
is about normal inflation no not current
inflation but that's normal inflation
rate
okay you're making me feel much better
that we are you know can financially do
it and now it is a plan to how we're
going to live life going forward yeah I
think that's more important in this
equation right because this idea that we
do nothing for 35 or 40 years is a good
way to Die Young
right I had a grandfather that did that
and my dad did the opposite he retired
at 55.
um unfortunately he did pass at 65 but
he always said for that 10 years that he
didn't know how he had time to go to
work before he retired because he was
volunteering and constantly doing things
yeah yeah plug into something it doesn't
necessarily have to create an income but
here's the other thing you probably have
some skill sets that you could apply
without breaking a sweat you might end
up making the most money you ever made
in your life and not break a sweat
foreign
Encore you take a bow after the curtains
come back up right
right
that's what both both my father-in-law
and my dad have done that
I did not hear that I said both my
father-in-law and my dad have done that
found something completely uh off out of
out of out of the realm of possibility
when they were doing their their career
jobs in in their late 60s and 70s and
it's been transformative it's been great
and they're made more than they did at
their original career both of them yeah
That's Not Unusual by the way it doesn't
have to be volunteer work is my point
it's okay to make money there's nothing
wrong with that um and it's just the
weird thing is you can end up doing it
with less effort because there's no
pressure
and so it's just kind of you just kind
of lean into it and it goes and then you
can tell not the boss quote unquote what
you really think but you can have your
opinion and say it out loud and if
you're a good leader you want somebody
who has an informed opinion that they're
not afraid to say out loud because it
helps the whole product become better
yeah and then you become a gift to the
organization and exactly or start your
own thing that you've always thought
about even if it doesn't require you
know you work three days a week at it
you hire two people that work 40 hours
and run you a little small business and
all of a sudden that's thinking things
making more money and you're made in
your life and it's just silly what you
can do when you don't have to
you know it's pretty amazing uh Lindsay
is with us in Boulder Colorado hi
Lindsay welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so my question is about my
um children I have two teenage boys and
my question is about really so that they
feel like they're being treated fairly
with um what we spend on their
extracurricular activities my older son
is 16 and he's very involved in a
whitewater kayaking team wants to try
out for the national team here in the
spring we spend a lot of money on this
activity and my other son is pretty
basic I mean he you know plays School
sports that are very reasonable and um
is this your issue is this their issue
yeah this is a this is uh uh this is
inside your heart not theirs you can't
make your boys feel anything
what you can do is treat them fairly
and if one loves one thing that happens
to be more expensive and the other I
mean there's not a dollar amount Ledger
like that right
right yeah it's okay you're doing fine
you're doing great
well my other question we told our kids
growing up that there's nothing Fair
unless it's got the tilt-a Whirl and got
cotton candy other than that it ain't
Fair
okay I mean my question too is you know
he he my older son worked mostly in the
summertime
um and he has contributed a little bit
but at some point it's like um well if
you want to limit what you're spending
on white water rafting that's your
choice but you don't have to do that to
be fair for the other to the other side
and don't use your other son as a reason
to limit your spending you be the adult
that make that choice yeah and just go
this is kind of out of control we're
going to back it down a little bit here
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and host
of the Dr John deloney show is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions and you're welcome to join us
through the holidays if you're going
over the river and through the woods to
Grandmother's house and we're on your
way if you want to stop and hang out
we've got free homemade cookies every
day and coffee is on us and people's
Grandma's uh Big Bad Wolves over the
river and through the woods to
Grandmother's house we go as a song John
that's a song I was taking a Little Red
Riding Hood yeah little Hood red and hot
I'll I'll go I'll go with my bet on that
one yeah okay it's good that's why
you're here for the commentary yeah
oh Anyway come visit us we'd love to
have you and you can also visit the debt
free stage which is what Alan and Amy
did they're here to do their debt free
scream hey guys how are you they're
great fantastic Dave cool good to have
you guys so tell me how much debt have
you guys paid off
194 000. all right how long did that
take nine years a little over nine years
wow and your range of income during that
time we start off around 93 dropped to
50 and went back up to 180 a little over
180. well there's a nice move so what do
you guys do for a living
I'm a it vendor management I help manage
vendor relationships and look for cost
saves for I.T groups okay
and I am a virtual assistant I have my
own business as a virtual assistant but
I was also a homeschool Mom very good
for many many years yeah good for you
guys well well done all right so what
kind of debt was the 194 000. all of it
was our home you paid
all right looking at weird people so
what's this house worth uh 400. wow very
nice how much have you got in
Investments
uh a little over 500. so you're bumping
up on the baby steps a millionaire
number huh oh yes sir way to go guys
proud of you very cool Dave I do have a
question around there that I've never
heard I've been listening to you since
1995. wow uh so around that is
calculating that is how do we do I'm a
military military and so I have that
pension as well as another pension and
I've looked at very different many
multiple resources how do we calculate
pensions into your net worth you don't
it's technically not an asset it's just
a it's an income stream you can't do
anything with it so it's not an asset so
technically I mean if you want to give
it a present value and say you know I'm
getting paid fifty thousand dollars a
year and it would take five hundred
thousand dollars to do that I count it
as 500. you could do that but
um the good news is is that you're going
to have a great net worth and a great
pension thank you for your service oh my
pleasure I'll call you millionaire Alan
no no no
I think you made it bro
so tell us the story what started you
guys on this Ramsey stuff nine years ago
no no I'll let her talk about nine years
ago I've been on this journey like I
said since the early 90s so yes um
for a really long time and
we've been dead freaks we accept the
house since about 2008. and then we're
just running a town home that we weren't
sure if we were going to keep or not so
we were not focused on paying that off
and then in 2009 we found out he was
going to be deployed to Afghanistan so
we put everything on hold except
investing
and then in 2012 that townhouse flooded
oh no so we had to rebuild our townhouse
from the studs I'm thankful we had
insurance and the kids had a good
attitude
in 2013 we sold that house and built our
current home so that's when we kind of
started the Journey of paying this this
data off and then we were also a
Financial Peace University coordinators
oh well thank you you're welcome it was
a lot of fun and our students really
just got us excited and we were like you
know oh we can do this
yeah it's doable it's doing what's right
there we just got to go get it so in the
meantime we also cash flowed well over a
hundred thousand dollars for braces
College you know life oh yeah absolutely
actually um so our children we cash
flowed through that two Associates
degrees and a bachelor's degree both of
our kids got their associate's degree in
high school and our daughter just
graduated in May with her bachelor's
degree in 19. WoW cash flowed all debt
free way to go guys scholarships ding
ding yes that was efficient yes
absolutely
well done you guys well how's it feel to
be a hundred percent free
no it's it's absolutely amazing it's
kind of surreal because you don't
realize it you wake up sometimes you
just just a great example about a month
ago I said hey let's just go up to the
uh the ark encounter and we just know we
have the budget there because we've
already increased our given we increased
our saving so now we can increase our
doing so there you go it's great just to
be able to take her to Savannah so we
just we just pick a week and a quarter
or every couple months and say where you
want to go and it's you don't have any
concerns because it's all Cash live like
no one else later you can live and give
like no one else well done good for you
guys yes what do you tell people you've
coordinated classes you're millionaires
almost you uh 100 debt free house and
everything what's the secret to managing
money well to getting out of debt what
do they need to do if they're listening
uh for me it's uh first thing is you you
need to pray you know you've got to get
wisdom from above you can't get wisdom
from yourself a second surround yourself
with smarter people and a great example
not to teach your horn but Dave I was
very ignorant in money I had some idea
but when I saw you met you in Jackson
and started listening to you I just got
educated and of course I listened to
other personalities so educate yourself
on that surround yourself with good
people but um I tell her one thing is is
if you're going to fail fail small and I
mean by that is
when you uh when something goes wrong if
you fall off the wagon don't make it to
where you don't feel like you can
recover ah that's good so you can
recover
Ernie then uh 30. bounce back fourth I
say reward yourself as you go like the
first time we paid off before the house
we paid off all her other debt and my
student loans
yeah yeah about a hundred and some
thousand but that's another conversation
but what we did is when you paid off the
first one because we didn't consolidate
at first we just paid them off I took
her to Wendy's just to celebrate but
when we paid
well that was the first my heart just
started beating fast but when we paid it
all off uh we went to Ruth's Chris so as
you go through your journey reward
yourself small now we're picking up okay
all right what was your um what was the
best uh disagreement you you all got in
over the last decade oh her
her trucks when we first got married she
always wanted a truck and we had a
minivan and our mother-in-law my
mother-in-law has been always great but
she made the comments I hope I don't
have to come pick you guys up when the
van breaks down again so we were debt
free we had money and shaming from the
Mother-in-law no no no we don't have to
pick you up on the side of the road what
kind of man did you marry Amy so we uh
she wanted it she always wanted a truck
and I wanted to get her a truck but so I
found a new one that I had had a lot of
major discounts I got a lot of uh uh
with military discounts and then I had
bought an old truck to help us move into
the house that I actually traded it in
sold it for more than I paid for it and
I went to the dealer for five days and
the last day the guy goes say Mr jobson
we have your office for you so just real
not top numbers but it was like a 43 000
truck 42 and I had him down to 21.5 out
the door and I got them to throw in the
one-year maintenance in that package too
very cool and we looked at the used ones
we could find one of like 25 or 30 or 40
000 miles and I said we're just gonna
we're gonna buy I'm gonna get you the
new truck so if she was not four because
I had him the Platinum version down too
but she uh she said no the XLT version's
fine so she's got her F-150s and she
still has it with over 200 000 miles Amy
you
I I just don't see F-150 when I look at
you she's all at 150. that's pretty cool
steering wheel and complaining license
plate complete F-150 girl okay I got it
yes I I have adjusted my Paradigm all
right hey guys we've got uh the live and
give bundle for you as a way of saying
congratulations it's got The Total Money
Makeover the baby steps millionaires
books in it it's got Financial Peace
University membership for a year in it
so bring the kiddos up and tell us their
current names and ages these days this
is to Ava she's 19. and this is so he's
also a Chick-fil-A scholar all right um
he got the Chick-fil-A scholarship this
year and doing really well in school how
old is he he's 17 17. all right very
good all right Allen and Amy Ava and Asa
from South Carolina
194 paid off in nine years house and
everything counted down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
oh yeah
yeah
love it
well done man that's fun
Merry Christmas America this is the
Ramsay show
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
26 3 and 4 you will keep in perfect
peace those whose minds are steadfast
because they trust in you trust in the
Lord forever for the Lord the Lord
himself is the rock eternal
corgien boom said if you look at the
world you'll be distressed if you look
within you'll be depressed
but if you look at Christ you'll be at
rest oh Corey well done well played so
the uh live and give bundle that we give
to each of the debt-free screamers is on
sale
if you want to do a living give bundle
you can break it up and you'd have three
gifts in there uh one for yourself if
you wanted like the baby steps
Millionaire's book and give away the
Total Money Makeover book and give away
Financial Peace University all three are
in there
and uh of course when you get the live
and give box it's a bundle it all comes
in a neat box you can give it all to
somebody uh as a gift it's only 99 now
Financial Peace University is normally
99 so that means the two books are like
free which is like fifty dollars worth
of books free so this is like 30
something percent off right
so it's a good deal the live and give
box or bundle or whatever we want to
call it Total Money Makeover book A year
of Financial Peace University and baby
steps millionaires all at
ramseysolutions.com
box Shelby is in Boise Idaho hi Shelby
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi there thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so um I want your advice I want your
opinion um my husband and I have a
student loan debt um it's mine uh 99
000
um and we used to have 12 Grand of
credit card debt and we're down to five
thousand six hundred so we're feeling
really good about that
um my question to you is I was listening
to the podcast
um from a couple weeks ago and I didn't
realize that with my husband's stock he
invested stock in the company he worked
for about ten thousand
um I didn't think about it the fact that
we kind of have all our eggs in one
basket should we pull that and use that
to pay down our debt or should we leave
it no you should use it it's not in a
it's not in a retirement account it's
just vested stock it's stock option is a
benefit
yes yeah just cash it out
yeah you would not borrow on a credit
card to buy stock and in effect that's
the net effect of what you've done
accidentally
yeah so yeah I would undo that and just
cash it out and and pay it down and
you're gonna have plenty of time to
invest later and invest in good mutual
funds inside your retirement account
once you get rid of these stinking loans
right
yes what's your household income Shelby
um we make between my husband and I we
make 94 a year before taxes great how
long y'all been married two years
seven so you have two kids yeah good
okay well so I'm I'm proud for the
progress you've made I want you to turn
the fire up hotter
and get it done faster because I I want
you to win we love you and we want you
to go out there and kill it okay so get
her done kiddo well done well done well
played Jessica is in Billings Montana hi
Jessica welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave my husband and I have been on
your plan for about the last five years
we
have done 3B for the last two and we've
decided to go back to doing four
um we're just feeling really discouraged
and not being able to afford a house
where we we are here in Montana and just
feeling like we're still years away even
after we've been saving for the last
four and I just wondered if you had any
advice for us
how much have you saved
we have a twenty thousand dollar
emergency fund and 47 500 in a down
payment fund
what's your household income
between my husband and I at 75 000 a
year you need to go buy a house
we tried we've been trying so we looked
at a house yesterday for 265 which is
really affordable for our area and
I know you recommend the 15-year loan um
but that seems Way Out Of Reach so on a
30 the payments would be between 17 and
18 1800 a month which is more like 35
percent of our take-home pay instead of
25. you're not discouraged you're
throwing a fit because you can't buy the
house you want that's not the same as
being discouraged
yeah
okay we haven't been able to stop
anything lower than that yeah keep
looking you need to find a home that you
can afford that is a blessing don't buy
something that's a curse because you uh
because you didn't look hard enough I
mean sometimes this isn't a an adventure
this house hunting thing
um you don't have an unlimited budget
you make seventy thousand dollars a year
you have forty seven thousand dollars to
put down don't put your family into a
crisis just to become a homeowner but
also don't don't say home ownership's
Out Of Reach in Billings Montana it's
not
you can do this but you know it may not
be the house you saw yesterday and and
yeah I would do it on a 15-year fixed
where the payments no more than a fourth
of your take-home pay why because I want
you to be millionaires later and I don't
want this house to ride you I want you
to ride the house
Dave I
Sheila and my wife and I did something
that's not really it's not the baby
steps
um but we found ourselves in this
situation and tell me if this is crazy
we as a couple decided we are going to
do essentially a
another gazelle Sprint so that we can
afford this down payment of a house and
we decided just to lock things down in
the middle for a limited amount of time
I think we said nine months something
like that and we're just going to work
bananas I'll take an extra job and I'm
gonna adjunct here I'm gonna do that and
let's just accelerate this process real
fast get this down payment so that we
can then move this thing along the only
thing that's not the baby steps there is
just we teach you to be intentional not
intense right and you said in order to
get the house I want I'm gonna I'm gonna
we're gonna we're gonna turn up the heat
yeah we're gonna go for it but and we
decided together it like yeah yeah both
of you work extra no vacations no eating
out and you go back to gazelle intensity
and you take your 47 and you make it 75
right and let's do this for six months
and let's just be bananas about it and
then it then we're gonna have no
problems yeah but you the the problem is
when you do a little bit of everything
nothing gets done that's right and so
you you start losing Death By A Thousand
Cuts then and that's what I'm afraid of
here uh and and so it's just
it is
um
it's not all Skittles and rainbows when
you go look at houses
no it's the worst because you always see
something you can't afford always we're
drawing a house plan to build next
summer
and um the uh the guy helping us with it
actually added the numbers wrong
accidentally
and so when we actually added them right
the house was like ridiculous or like
we're not doing that
and we can afford to do it whatever but
it's just like it's huge you know
there's someone just no we're not doing
that let's fix this so we've gone
through and cut the dadgum thing down
but it's it's depressing it hurts right
to go backward after you were up is
depressing and I could afford it right
so I have the choice but if you don't
have the choice and you've got to cut
down because it doesn't fit the budget
or it doesn't fit the situation it's
depressing yeah if you you know it's
don't go drive new cars if you're in
getting ready to buy a new one I used
one yeah because a new one of those you
know blow your dadgum mind and then you
can't you can't return you can't yeah
and don't fall in the Trap of a
frustration of frustration and
frustration if you're around a child
especially like a toddler you know they
get annoyed they get annoyed they get
annoyed and then they just hit something
or they just shove something over or
they bite somebody don't just go see a
house go see a house go see a house and
then just get so frustrated they buy
something yeah because it's just the way
it is and you don't understand just walk
walk away
yeah yeah that's what you back up take a
cold shower get house fever I mean it's
a it's a real thing I I understand it's
easy to be oh listening to her like I
threw a temper tantrum the other day I
wanted to buy something and again I can
afford it
I have there was no reason on the planet
to buy it none zero except I just wanted
it and I that's my temper tantrum Dave
was at me yeah you know I mean the
grown-up me was telling the kid me I
can't do this and the kid that's what
we're doing with this house plants so
like the grown-up me looked at that and
went that's just dumber than crap we're
not doing that and Sharon goes that's
ridiculous we're not doing that and I'm
going but I like it and I want it I want
it I want it I want it and yeah I mean
that's human freaking nature and if I
who teach this stuff every year for 30
years fall for it then Jessica in
Billings Montana you have permission to
fall for it too right but you've got to
fight the inner child do the next right
thing the one on the cereal aisle that
throws a fit and says I want it I want
it no call the wambulance take six jobs
build up your down payment or lower your
price point that you're looking at and
quit looking at houses you can't afford
and that's what you got to do it's a
pain in the butt this thing called
grown-up Phil that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books our thanks to
Austin Ben James Zack and Andrew the
booth dudes they make it happen I am
Dave Ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over
15 million people listen to the Ramsey
show every week a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country to find a
station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
foreign